today i'm going to do a quick review of
an odesk profile and give my tips and
feedback on how to improve it
hi i'm evan carmichael i believe in
entrepreneurs welcome to another
technology tuesday today i'm answering a
question for one of my youtube followers
love you guys bobby wrote in to say
hello everyone i love your video it
helped me a lot thanks bobby please
allow me your thoughts about my odus
profile hope you won't give it a hard
time i'm just a newbie wanting to learn
more in order to be hired thank you so
bobby this one is for you i'm gonna head
over to my computer check out your
profile and give you some feedback okay
so i've loaded up bobby's profile the
first thing i always look at is their
picture and what i love about this one
is bobby's smiling he uh he's got a
professional college shirt on
it's a warm picture makes me relate to
him and makes me feel like hey bob is a
nice hard-working guy and and that's
important the only thing i would fix on
this is it's a little low resolution
it's a little blurry a little hard to
see so i try to take another picture try
to keep that same shirt keep that same
smile just take a higher quality picture
the next thing i look at is the overview
and here in the overview
you know working for seven years as area
operations in charge of a third-party
marketing services company of nestle
philippines unilever from project
planning to reviewing and answering more
than 50 plus emails daily i'm the one
responsible for managing our social
media account as one of the
administrator for a non-profit community
but doing research post editing pictures
okay so a couple things one you want to
make you want to make sure as you go
through this not to have any errors
right so as one of the administrators
right that should be plural uh as well
this
is boring right it's a boring overview
this is like a typical resume and now
you look like everybody else if you're a
social media manager i would say i love
working with social media i spend all my
day on social media something like show
me your passion for social media show me
how you love
helping businesses with their social
media why is it important to you right
like that's going to make you jump off
the page where most people are going to
be super boring and give me exactly what
you gave me here so definitely check for
spellings and grammar mistakes but give
me some more passion and energy and love
especially off this top because it's
looking pretty boring
next thing go down and look at your
tests so we look at the test you've done
two tests okay the first is english
spelling test 75 is okay but not great
and if i'm hiring somebody who's going
to be a social media manager
i may need somebody who can speak
english really well and write english
really well right if you're going to be
writing to people and connecting with
them then your english should be at a
high level and maybe it is you just
didn't do so well on the test uh some
positions i don't care you know if i'm
hiring a computer programmer if i'm
hiring a graphic designer
uh you know english spelling and grammar
is not at the top of the list because
they're only communicating with me as
long as we can have a dialogue but if
you're doing anything public facing
anything when you're dealing with
potential customers your english should
be higher so if i'm looking at that then
i'm saying
i don't know if i want to hire bobby to
be my social media manager so
get to work and boost this up the next
is social media marketing test 57
bobby baby what are we doing here you're
a social media manager you got to get
that score up brother because i'm
looking at that and saying wow i am not
going to hire this guy because he almost
failed the social media marketing test
so work on your two tests and because
you don't have any experience yet i'd
add more tests put more tests in there
look at anything that's related to
social media at all or writing or
english anything take that test study
practice don't just go into it put
effort into it and have high scores
because
if you have a high score i'm much more
likely to hire you okay
next you don't have any jobs so i mean
you're just getting started you want to
get some jobs as soon as you can even if
you're doing it at a below market rate
just to get some feedback right i want
to see five stars here so you want to
make sure you get a few jobs under your
belt and then the thing that will help
is get a portfolio where's your
portfolio where can i see the work that
you've done right show me the kinds of
work that you're doing show me some
client examples if you can't share what
you did with nestle or some of your
clients just make something up do it for
yourself do it for a fake company just
show what you can do right if you're
creating content you're making a
presentation design make a fake
presentation design make a presentation
design for evan carmichael right just
put something up here so i can get a
sense of your skills because you don't
have any uh work experience yet all
those other things so there's five
things we talked about right the picture
the overview the test that you've taken
the jobs that you've had and the the
score and the portfolio you don't have a
job yet so that's always going to be a
hurt against you it's going to be a
strike against you so there's other five
things picture overview tax and
portfolio you gotta amp that up if you
make that really special then you will
step off the page when somebody's
looking to hire their next social media
manager and they say we gotta have bobby
on our team so bobby i hope that helped
it looks like you have a little bit more
work to do so good luck on that for
those of you watching if you have a
question about odesk or your profile or
another question related
entrepreneurship leave it in the
comments below and i'll see if i can
make a video response for you if you
like this video you want to see more
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
subscribe to the newsletter continue to
believe and i'll see you soon